NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMMENTING ON
THE CORONAVIRUS JUST MOMENTS AGO
AS THERE ARE 62 CONFIRMED CASES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE HAVEN’T LOST ANYBODY YET
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP THAT
IN TACT.
THERE’VE BEEN NO DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES AT ALL.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT GOING
AFTER THE MEDIA.
FIRST, HE’S LOOKING TO LOOM
LARGE OVER A MAJOR DENDRITIC
PRIMARY.
SET FOR A BIG RALLY IN
SOUTH CAROLINA TWO HOURS FROM
NOW AS DEMOCRATS GET READY TO
FACE OFF IN THE PALMETTO STATE.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SPLINTERING AS
CANDIDATES CONTINUE TO SLAM
BERNIE SANDERS AND WARNED THAT
HIS MESSAGE OF SOCIALISM WILL
DOOM THE PARTY’S PROSPECTS IN
20.
>> I BELIEVE IF BERNIE SANDERS
GETS THE NOMINATION, HE’LL LOSE
THE TO DONALD TRUMP.
HE’LL MAKE SURE THAT THE SENATE
STAYS IN REPUBLICAN HANDS.
BILL FLIPPED THE HOUSE BACK TO
THE REPUBLICANS, AND EVEN DOWN
BALLOT HE’S GOING TO HURT THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> THE FACT THAT SOMEONE LISTS
HIMSELF AS AN OFFICIAL
INDEPENDENT EXCEPT AS PRESIDENT
TO RUN
>> Dana: BERNIE REMAINS
DEFIANT THROUGH IT ALL.
>> WE ARE BUILDING A MOVEMENT
THAT CANNOT BE STOPPED.
AND WHEN MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
STAND UP AND FIGHT BACK, NOTHING
ON EARTH CAN STOP US.
>> Dana: JOE BIDEN LOOKING FOR
A GAME CHANGER IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
STRONG POLLING IN THE STATE IS
PUTTING BIDEN IN A GOOD POSITION
BUT HIS CAMPAIGN IS STILL
PLAGUED BY MORE GAFFES, BIDEN
SAYING HE WAS NEVER ARRESTED IN
SOUTH AFRICA WHILE TRYING TO
MEET NELSON MANDELA.
>> BY ARRESTED, I MEAN I WAS NOT
ABLE TO MOVE.
THE COPS WOULD NOT LET ME GO,
MADE ME STAY WHERE I WAS.
I WASN’T ARRESTED, I WAS
STOPPED, I WAS NOT ABLE TO MOVE
WHERE I WANTED TO GO.
>> Dana: I DO WANT TO PLAY
THIS OUT FROM JAMES CLYBURN, THE
CONGRESS MEN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA
WHO ENDORSED JOE BIDEN.
HERE’S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> I WAS IN TEXAS ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO.
I TALKED TO THE FAITH COMMUNITY
DOWN THERE AND THEY WERE VERY,
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS SOMEBODY ON THE
TICKET WHO WOULD CAUSE DOWN
BALLOT CARNAGE.
>> Dana: INTERESTING THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT DOWN BALLOT
CARNAGE, GREG, AFTER BERNIE WAS
IN FULL POSITION TO WIN IN IOWA,
NEW HAMPSHIRE, NEVADA.
SOUTH CAROLINA HE MIGHT NOT BE
DOING THAT WELL BUT PULLING THE
PANIC ALARM MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT LATE.
>> Greg: THE DEMOCRATS HAD FOR
YEARS TO PREPARE FOR THIS MOMENT
AND TO BEAT THIS ORANGE DEMON
BEEN THE WORST HUMAN THAT EVER
LIVED.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
INSTEAD OF STUDYING FOR THE
EXAM, THEY DECIDED TO PLAY "
"FORTNITE" IN THEIR UNDERWEAR,
THEY CHASED PHANTOMS OF
IMPEACHMENT, COLLUSION,
DESTRUCTION, ACTUALLY FINDING A
CANDIDATE OR FIGURING OUT A WAY
BEHIND-THE-SCENES OR WHATEVER TO
DEAL WITH BERNIE -- I THINK
THE -- YOU KNOW HOW THEY ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT VOTER SUPPRESSION?
THEY SHOULD WORRY ABOUT VOTER
DEPRESSION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW THAT FEELS,
THE FIELD IS SO FLAWED THAT YOU
WEREN’T LOOKING FOR A VOTING
BOOTH, YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A
BRIDGE.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE A LOT OF
PEOPLE JUST AREN’T GOING TO VOTE
BECAUSE IT’S GOING TO BE, YOU
KNOW WHAT, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TRUMP FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS,
LIFE GOES PRETTY FAST.
>> Dana: THEY’LL HAVE ALL
THESE ADS, JESSE, LIKE HUXLEY
CLYBURN SAYING THAT BERNIE SANDE
WOULD HAVE CARNAGE.
>> Jesse: BERNIE DID NOT HAVE
A GOOD WEEK.
HIS MATH NOT ADDING UP ON
"60 MINUTES" AND AT THE DEBATE
REALLY MADE PEOPLE THINK AGAIN
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AND THAT’S
WHY DEMOCRATS ARE RATTLED.
JOE NEEDS A BIG WIN IN
SOUTH CAROLINA BECAUSE HE’S
RUNNING ON FUMES IN HIS
COALITION -- HE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE GUIDE TO WIN WHITE
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS AND HE’S
GOT WALLOPED BY EVERYBODY IN THE
FIELD OF THOSE ISSUES IN THE
FIRST THREE PRIMARIES.
AND HE’S SUPPOSED TO TURN THAT
HISPANICS AND HE LOST BY 30
POINTS TO BERNIE IN NEVADA WITH
HISPANICS.
HE ONLY BEAT BERNIE BY 10% WITH
BLACKS IN NEVADA.
HE’S NOT EVEN SPENDING ANY MONEY
AT SUPER TUESDAY.
HE SPENT ONLY 600,000 ON SUPER
TUESDAY.
BERNIE HAS SPENT $15 MILLION.
HE HAS TWICE THE AMOUNT OF FANS
HE HAS.
>> Dana: AND MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
HAS SPENT $600 MILLION.
GERALDO, I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
HOW SOUTH CAROLINA COULD BE A
STARTING POINT FOR HIM.
>> I’VE BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
THIS COMMUNITY, IN THE STATE.
SO I FEEL VERY GOOD ABOUT IT.
IT’S BEEN A LAUNCHING PAD FOR
BARACK AND IT’LL BE THE
LAUNCHING PAD FOR ME.
>> Dana: SOUTH CAROLINA PUNCH
ABOVE ITS WEIGHT IN TERMS OF
EARLY STATES BECAUSE IT’S CRUNCH
TIME WHEN YOU GET THERE.
>> Geraldo: I THINK PEOPLE ARE
UNDERESTIMATING THE IMPACT
SOUTH CAROLINA WILL HAVE ON THE
BIDEN CANDIDACY.
I BELIEVE HE WILL WIN DECISIVELY
AND THAT WILL CHANGE THE
CONVERSATION.
THE QUESTION IS WILL ANYBODY BE
FOCUSED ON POLITICS WHEN WE ONLY
CARE ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH RIGHT
NOW?
PUBLIC HEALTH AND POLITICS OF
THE SAME STORY RIGHT NOW AND
WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW IS HOW
WOULD YOU DEAL -- THEY DON’T
WANT TO SEE BIDEN SNIPING AT
TRUMP RIGHT NOW, THEY DON’T WANT
TO SEE BLOOMBERG SNAPPING AT
TRUMP.
I’M DEEPLY DISTRESSED BY WHAT
PELOSI AND SCHUMER DID IN
ATTACKING TRUMP AND UNDERMINING
THE CONFIDENCE WE HAVE IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS IS REALLY, REALLY BAD.
BUT I BELIEVE BIDEN CAN PULL OFF
A MIRACLE HERE.
THIS IS ROCKY.
HE’S A DECENT PERSON.
HE’S NOT MY GUY.
I WOULD NOT VOTE FOR HIM -- MAY
BE, I VOTE FOR HIM.
BUT I THINK YOU WILL AS A RESULT
OF SOUTH CAROLINA, BLACK PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY WILL CARRY THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE WITH MOMENTUM AND
THAT A REPORT SUPER TUESDAY EVEN
THOUGH AS JESSE RIGHTLY POINTS
OUT HE SPENT ABOUT $0.06.
>> Emily: IF I CAN,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA COMPRISE 60% OF
THE DEMOCRATIC VOTING BLOC AND
THE MOST CONSERVATIVE OF THAT
BLOCK.
THE PAST WEEK, WE’VE SEEN BIDEN
LEAD A GOOD AVERAGE BETWEEN FOUR
AND 20 POINTS AT AVERAGED 12.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT IT’S HIS TO
LOSE.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU SEE THE
TWO POLLS FROM CNN OUT OF TEXAS
AND CALIFORNIA ABOUT BERNIE?
BY CAMILLA, A MILLION.
21 POINTS IN CALIFORNIA AND 9 IN
TEXAS.
BIDEN SAYING THAT’S GOING BE MY
A LAUNCHING PAD, BUT WILL
MOMENTUM BE ENOUGH AFTERWARDS
WHEN WE GO TO SUPER TUESDAY WITH
BERNIE LOOKING LIKE A COMPLETE
KING?
>> Geraldo: MAY I?
I BELIEVE THAT SOUTH CAROLINA
WILL AFFECT THOSE NUMBERS.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT TEXAS AND
CALIFORNIA, BUT BECAUSE IT IS SO
CLOSE TO DAYS LATER,
SOUTH CAROLINA COMMITTED USE
>> Dana: I WANT TO ASK GREG
ONE MORE QUESTION.
>> Greg: I’M BUSY.
>> Dana: MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG
WE DID COME IN SECOND IN THOSE
TWO CONTESTS, BUT WE GO TO TALK
ABOUT HIM.
WHAT’S GOING ON THERE?
>> Greg: HE’S GOT TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL.
HE’S A SOPHOMORE IN
HIGH SCHOOL -- HE DID KNOW THAT,
DIDN’T YOU?
THERE’S A LOT OF EGO WHY PEOPLE
STAY IN THESE RACES.
IT WAS THE SAME THING IN 2016.
>> Dana: A LOT OF CAMPAIGNS DO
NOT END BECAUSE THE CANDIDATE
WANTS TO, IT’S BECAUSE THEY RUN
OUT OF MONEY.
ON WEDNESDAY YOU’LL SEE THIS
RACE NARROW.
>> Greg: IF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ARE VOTING FOR BERNIE SANDERS,
WOULDN’T THEY ALSO VOTE WITH
EVERYONE WITH A T NEXT TO THEIR
NAMES?
THIS IS WHAT I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
>> Jesse: SOME PEOPLE GO IN
AND THEY SPLIT THE TICKET.
>> Dana: IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT, IT’S AN 80% OF
DEMOCRATS SAID THEY WOULD NEVER
VOTE FOR BERNIE OR FOR